[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i was reading ed bouchette's column
and uh he covers the steelers he's been
covering the steelers since 1985 i
believe
and uh his column with the athletic
summing up last night
here is uh the last line of his column
it was more than the end
of a season it might be the end of an
era
ed bouchette joins us ed was at the end
of an era
for ben roethlisberger and the steelers
well we're gonna
probably find out rather quickly dan um
he's do a 15 million roster bonus in the
middle of march
and they're going to have to decide
whether to pay that whether to wrap it
into an extension if you will
somehow or if he retires i don't think
you'll see him play anywhere else
he doesn't want to but um they have a
massive
problem with the salary cap they only
have 34 players under contract some of
their better guys or
free agents this does not look like a
team that's going to contend
this next season and if you're ben
roethlisberger why would you want to
play if you can't contend
what happened after going 11-0
you know they i still haven't gotten a
straight answer why they
went to this short passing game but it
was working
he got rid of the ball everybody knows
faster than anybody in the league after
spending most of his career holding on
to it longer than anyone in the league
and then defenses caught up to him uh
they started ganging around the
the line of scrimmage all of a sudden
their running game was ineffective uh
they were batting down ben's passes at
the line because they knew they couldn't
get to him in a sack
and um uh for whatever reason they did
not adjust to throwing it deeper until
late late late when did you know that
the steelers were in trouble last night
how about the first snap of the game
[Laughter]
uh that that was bad um
but you know they have the kind of
firepower to overcome that and we saw
that in the second half
uh and then ben just did not look good
at all for most of that first half he
was
not only throwing three interceptions he
was throwing uh
overthrowing guys um throwing wide
behind them on slants that were open i
mean he had some receivers open he just
didn't hit him
and why there was such a difference
in the second half with his accuracy i
don't know but we've seen a lot of that
this year dan where
he's had a terrible half one or the
other and then a
a big ben half the next one
are the browns going to be in the market
for a
high-end quarterback are they are they
are steelers i should say are they going
to be going into this
draft or are they going to go into the
off-season thinking
you know can we kick the tires on matt
stafford or
maybe one of the younger quarterbacks uh
sam darnold if he would be available or
somebody in the draft what do you think
the philosophy's going to be
i think it would be if ben retires i
think they would just go with mason
rudolph
and um if there would be a quarterback
available in the first round in the 20s
where they're going to be drafting
that they like uh they could take them
but i don't see that happening
dan um i think you're looking at 2022
before they get
another quarterback they're not going to
trade for one of those guys first of all
they need the ca
the draft capital to rebuild their team
and why would you bring a guy like
darnold in who's going to be on the last
year of his contract anyway
um so and they're not going to
sign a free agent they don't have the
money they're going to be 20 million
right now they're projected to be 20
million over the cap
with only 34 players under contract
assess the cleveland browns with what
you saw last night
that maybe what you didn't or did see
earlier in the season with the cleveland
browns
well i saw some toughness some moxie
they were facing all kinds of
um dilemmas without their head coach
without both line coaches and then
they're
losing uh offensive linemen they didn't
have their best cornerback
uh they didn't have their number three
corner back and they came in here and
just cleaned up
um they dan they they showed me a lot
and so did
the quarterback yeah and i i talked
about this a couple of times already
today of
finding your identity like knowing who
you are cleveland knew
and knows who they are i don't think
pittsburgh knows or knew who they were
last night
they've been two different teams dan
they were the 11-0
team and then they finished one and five
and they barely beat some of those teams
that they won
11-0 dallas cowboys it was a terrible
game for them
the ravaged baltimore ravens you know
missing
half 13 they barely beat them uh they
had to come back to beat the colts their
only victory in their last six games
and that was a big comeback from 17 down
i think that game actually gave them
hope but um
they have some really tough decisions
and i don't know that they're going to
be very many good ones coming up
i know it's always a delicate situation
when you're dealing with
hall of famers and you know like drew
brees with the saints did
you know desean payton really want him
back or i kind of publicly want him back
how do the steelers if they want to give
the message
to ben deliver that message in a
professional
polite respectable way that they don't
want him back
you know they couldn't do that with troy
paula model that was uh
that was getting kind of ugly he almost
left to go to another team but he
finally retired
um ben i think will realize it on his
own
and i think what they'll do is tell them
lay out
the rebuilding they're going to have to
go through and do you want to go through
this with us
how do you think why why would he want
to i mean he
he's made enough money he's not coming
back to
he has 19 million um on the table
extra to be made he's a 41 million cap
hit he would be 22 million if he retired
uh cap hit but he has 19 million he
could make
i don't think that's his motivation he
wants to win
uh he desperately wanted to win another
super bowl and it doesn't look like
that's going to happen and i don't see
him going anywhere else then
football going to be on tvs in
pittsburgh this weekend
you know in the past uh once the season
ended abruptly in the playoffs uh
people lose interest but this is a
football town i think you'll see them uh
i think you'll see a lot of ratings
coming out of pittsburgh for the nfl
is there a more painful game in your
history of covering the steelers
than last week oh yeah yeah there's been
dan you mentioned i've been around
for a long time i remember the 94 afc
title game when they were like 10 point
favorites to beat san diego and go to
the super bowl and they
lost that was the worst that was
absolutely the worst
and their most recent loss before this
one in 2017 at home to jacksonville
after they went 13-3 and by the way that
game was 45-42
they've given up a lot of points in
these last two playoff games
both at home ed thanks for getting up we
appreciate it
and uh enjoy the off-season all right
dan thank you that's ed buschette
he's been covering the team as i
mentioned and he did he's been covering
them for a long time 1985.
he uh covers the steelers for the
athletic